>> IS IT THROUGH WE'LL GIVE
$450,000 TO BORDER CROSSERS WHO
WERE SEPARATED?
>> Harris: HEAD SCRATCHING
SILENCE.
DID YOU SEE IT?
A QUICK LOOK ON THE ESCALATOR.
THAT'S ALL PRESIDENT BIDEN
OFFERED WHEN HE WAS QUESTIONED
ON A "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REPORT.
THE STORY HIS ADMINISTRATION
MAY PAY $450,000 PER PERSON TO
PEOPLE WHO COME HERE WHO SUED
OVER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
SEPARATING THEM AT THE BORDER.
REPUBLICANS ARE TEARING INTO
THE PRESIDENT OVER THE IDEA
THAT COULD COST SOME $1 MILLION
PER FAMILY AND AS MUCH AS $1
BILLION OVERALL.
HERE IS SENATOR MARSHA
BLACKBURN ON "THE FAULKNER
FOCUS" ASKING HOW THAT MUST
MAKE HARD WORKING AMERICAN
FAMILIES FEEL.
>> WE WOUL